My name is Yana and I'm a trainee psychological wellbeing practitioner. I read the clinical psychologist collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one. And this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself.
我叫亚娜，是一名心理健康实践实习生。我读了临床心理学家集体的那本书。我觉得书中讲述的各种不同故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的经历真的非常有趣。通往这个职业的途径居然有这么多，而且没有哪一种是成为临床心理学家的唯一完美方式，这让我大为惊叹。这在某种程度上让我充满了信心，让我觉得自己并没有做错，同时也减轻了我的心理压力。
So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me, you will not put the book down once you start. Continuing professional development. We all know we should be doing it, but what happens when the HCPC
所以，如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有些心神不定，我绝对会推荐你读这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始阅读，你就绝对舍不得放下这本书。持续专业发展。我们都知道我们应该这样做，但当HCPC
actually checks? Today we are giving you the lowdown, the real truth on CPD audits and what to expect. Hope you find it so useful. Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne, a qualified clinical psychologist. Now when it comes to continuing professional development, we ought to be keeping records for all stages of our career because it can be really useful at times of appraisal when you need to review your performance or perhaps even feed into reviewing somebody else's performance as well. But once we advance to becoming qualified,
真正进行检查时会发生什么呢？今天我们将向大家介绍关于CPD审核的内幕、真实的真相以及你所能期望的情况。希望你会觉得这非常有用。你好，欢迎收听《有抱负的心理学家》播客。我是玛丽安博士，一名合格的临床心理学家。现在，说到持续专业发展，我们应该在职业生涯的各个阶段都做好记录，因为这在绩效评估时非常有用，当你需要回顾自己的表现，或者可能为回顾他人的表现提供参考时，它都能派上用场。但一旦我们晋升为合格的从业者，
it means that in order to keep up our HCPC registration, that we need to be logging and potentially able to evidence the continuing professional development, the CPD that we are doing. This is not something we've covered in the podcast yet. And I do think that everybody at every stage of their career working towards a regulated profession will find this a really eye-opening episode. I do hope that's the case. If you do find it helpful please do drop me a like,
这就意味着为了保持我们的HCPC注册，我们需要记录并可能能够证明我们正在进行的持续专业发展，即CPD。这是我们播客中尚未涉及的内容。而且我坚信，无论处于职业生涯的哪个阶段、正在为成为受监管职业而努力的每一个人，都会觉得这是一期让人大开眼界的节目。我希望确实如此。如果你觉得它有帮助，请务必给我点个赞，
drop me a comment and subscribe to the channel wherever you get your podcasts for more. Thank you so much. I'll see you on the other side. Hi, just want to welcome along our guest for today, Dr. Carly Poynton. Hi Carly. Hi Mary Ann, nice to see you. Lovely to see you too. And thank you so much for coming and speaking to our audience about this very important topic because I know it's been a bit stressful at times for you too. Yeah, absolutely and unexpected but I knew it would come at some point. Yeah, so tell us then for those who, we've got people listening to this podcast or watching this on YouTube, all different stages of their career,
给我留个言，并在你获取播客的任何平台上订阅这个频道以获取更多内容。非常感谢。我们稍后再见。嗨，我只想欢迎我们今天的嘉宾卡莉·庞顿博士。嗨，卡莉。嗨，玛丽安，很高兴见到你。我也很高兴见到你。非常感谢你来和我们的听众谈论这个非常重要的话题，因为我知道这对你来说有时也有些压力。是的，绝对是的，而且在意料之外，但我知道它总会在某个时候到来。是的，那么请告诉我们，对于那些，收听这个播客或在YouTube上观看的人，他们处于职业生涯的不同阶段，
so some may already know what an HCPCPD audit is, others may not. Could you give us a little bit of an overview about that please, Carly? Absolutely, yeah. So every couple of years when registration comes around, the HCPC choose, I think it's 2.5% of the registrants to randomly select 2.5% of them to audit and that involves choosing registrants to look at their continuing professional development. So you have to provide evidence of what you've been doing over a two-year period and obviously we'll go into a little bit more detail as we talk but essentially you have to show two years of records and you have to do a little bit more of a deep dive on four to six pieces of CPD from those two years. Provide that back to the HCPC within a certain time frame,
所以有些人可能已经知道什么是HCPC CPD审核，而另能不知道。卡莉，你能给我们简单介绍一下吗？完全可以，是的。所以每隔几年，当需要重新注册时，HCPC会选择，我想大约是2.5%的注册人员，随机抽取2.5%的人进行审核，这就需要挑选注册人员来审查他们的持续专业发展。因此，你必须提供你在两年期间所做事情的证据，当然我们在谈话时会探讨更多细节，但本质上你必须展示两年的记录，并且你必须从这两年中挑选4到6项CPD进行更深入的剖析。在一定时间内将这些反馈给HCPC，
three months, in a particular style of evidence and of written reflection as well as a sort of chronological record around the work that you do. And it has to be against the standards that the HCPC expect to see. So it's something that you know you have to do and you should be keeping records. But when you get asked to do it, it can be quite a daunting experience because whilst we all develop as we go through our work, we don't necessarily reflect on it in the depth that the ACPC needs to see to ensure that you're continuing to develop and you're doing that for your benefit and the benefit of your clients that you work with. Okay, yeah, this does sound quite involved. I'm yet to be called, but I understand that when we get that call to re-register, and you've got to do that within a set window,
即三个月内，以特定的证据风格和书面反思，以及围绕你所做工作的某种时间顺序记录呈现出来。并且它必须符合HCPC期望看到的标准。所以这是一件你知道你必须去做并且应该保留记录的事情。但当你被要求去做这件事时，这可能会是一次相当令人生畏的经历，因为虽然我们在工作中不断成长，但我们不一定会以ACPC需要看到的深度去反思它，以确保你仍在持续发展，并且你这样做是为了你自己的利益以及你与之合作的客户的利益。好吧，是的，这听起来确实相当复杂。我还没被抽到过，但我了解到，当我们接到重新注册的电话时，你必须在规定的窗口期内完成，
otherwise you get unregistered. So for anyone who is already HCPC regulated, look out for that email. Because I don't think they send you a letter anymore. It's literally like an email. You've got to catch it and you've got to do it within a certain timeframe. So you log in to your HCPC login portal. And is it at that stage that you realise you've been one of the lucky 2.5%? So, yeah, so what happened with me was I noticed that probably like yourself, so I'm part of quite a few Facebook groups, one of them being the UK Psychologists in Private Practice group, and somebody had mentioned that they had been chosen and
否则你的注册就会被注销。所以对于任何已经受到HCPC监管的人来说，请留意那封电子邮件。因为我觉得他们不会再给你寄信了。这简直就像一封电子邮件。你必须抓住它，并且必须在一定时间内完成。你要登录你的HCPC登录门户网站。是不是在这个阶段你才意识到自己是那幸运的2.5%之一呢？是的，所以在我身上发生的事情是，我注意到可能和你一样，因为我是好几个Facebook群组的成员，其中一个就是英国私立心理学家群组，有人提到他们被选中了，
they said that on the breakdown of registration, the registration page, that their audit section was in red. So they hadn't received an email to say that they were going to be audited but their section was just in red so they assumed they might be. Whereas a couple of other people have commented underneath and said, No, I have received an email asking me to do the audit. So this alarm bell went off in my head because I've been qualified nearly 11 years. And I thought, even though it's supposed to be random, I just thought, oh, I just feel like
并且他们说在注册明细页面上，他们的审核部分是红色的。所以他们没有收到将要接受审核的电子邮件，但他们的部分变红了，所以他们猜测自己可能被选中了。而其他几个人在下面评论说，没有，我收到了一封要求我进行审核的电子邮件。所以这在我的脑海中敲响了警钟，因为我获得资质已经快11年了。我想，尽管这应该是随机的，但我只是觉得，哦，我只是觉得
fate might be it might be my turn. So I logged on to register and the section was in red, but I hadn't received an email either. And then lo and behold, a few days later, I just I did receive the email. So lots of people had the same sort of thing had happened for them. And funny enough, I supervised somebody in New Zealand. And she was a trainee of mine a good few years ago. and she had been asked to do her CPD in New Zealand at the same time.
命运可能就是这样，可能轮到我了。所以我登录注册系统，那个部分确实是红色的，但我也没有收到电子邮件。果不其然，几天后，我确实收到了电子邮件。所以很多人都遇到了同样的情况。说来也巧，我在新西兰督导过一个人。她几年前曾是我的实习生。而她几乎同时被要求在新西兰做她的CPD。
Just as a funny fact, in New Zealand, you can't re-register until you've given your CPD in. So actually, for all the psychologists that live over here in the UK, we've actually got a better deal because we can re-register and stay registered while we do our CPD, whereas in New Zealand you have to put your registration in and then you get your registration back. So we actually have a slightly better deal, so it takes the pressure off. So you can go on the register, you can put your registration in and then you put your CPD in by the end of May. So it's slightly less pressurised, to be honest,
作为一个有趣的事实，在新西兰，在提交CPD之前你是不能重新注册的。实际上，对于所有住在英国这里的心理学家来说，我们的待遇其实更好，因为我们可以在做CPD的同时重新注册并保持注册状态，而在新西兰，你必须提交注册申请，然后才能恢复注册。所以我们的待遇其实稍微好一些，这减轻了压力。所以你可以注册，提交你的注册申请，然后在5月底之前提交你的CPD。老实说，玛丽安，
Mary-Anne, than I thought it was going to be for that purpose. Yeah, because obviously when we're in private practice, and if you haven't got your registration, you potentially can't work, you can't earn any money. So I'm very glad for the UK system in that regard. This might sound like a silly question, but what counts as CPD for a qualified psychologist? So it's quite broad and varied. I mean, I did know, you know, I knew that things like reading journals, going to conferences, attending formal training courses, you know, those things are obvious, aren't they? You know, those are the things that spring to mind. And when you support assistant psychologists and trainees, and your peers, if you're a line manager as well, those things are
这比我最初想象的要轻松一些。是的，因为很明显，当我们在私立诊所工作时，如果你没有注册，你可能就无法工作，也无法赚钱。所以在这方面我非常庆幸有英国的制度。这听起来可能是一个愚蠢的问题，但对于合格的心理学家来说，什么算作CPD？它的范围很广，种类也很多。我的意思是，我确实知道，比如阅读期刊、参加会议、参加正式培训课程，你知道，这些事情是很显而易见的，对吧？你知道，这些是脑海中最先浮现的事情。当你支持助理心理学家和实习生，以及你的同龄人时，如果你也是直线经理，这些事情
obvious, aren't they? If you've supervised and managed people over time. If you're newly qualified, and perhaps you're starting out in your career, maybe some of the more subtle things might not be as obvious. Things like developing a new presentation or a training course, going through your personal development plan with your line manager, or going to a reflective practice session and talking things through with your peers and being able to write that up. Those things might not seem as obvious. When I went through my two years, and obviously going to clinical supervision, actually those discussions that you have are continuous professional development. I think people jump to the first most obvious thing,
不是很明显吗？如果你随着时间推移一直在督导和管理人员的话。如果你是刚获得资格，也许刚开始你的职业生涯，那么一些更微妙的事情可能就不那么明显了。比如开发一个新的演示文稿或培训课程，与你的直线经理一起经历你的个人发展计划，或者参加反思性实践会议，与同龄人讨论各种事情并能够将其写下来。这些事情可能看起来没那么明显。当我经历了我的两年期，当然还有去进行临床督导，实际上你们进行的那些讨论就是持续专业发展。我认为人们会直接想到最显眼的事情，
like attending a course, and think that you've got to have a big long list of courses that you've attended, and actually it isn't. And what the HCPC do is they give you the categories of educational type work, you know, CPD that you can provide, formal, informal, indirect type of CPD, but also voluntary, you know, voluntary work that you can do, things that will help to support to show that you're growing in your role, but also what benefits you and what benefits
比如参加一门课程，然后认为你必须有一大串你参加过的课程清单，而实际上并非如此。HCPC为你提供了教育类工作的类别，你知道，你可以提供的CPD，正式的、非informal的、间接类型的CPD，还有志愿服务，你知道，你可以做的志愿工作，这些事情将有助于证明你在角色中不断成长，同时也对你有益，对……
in the ACPC they talk about service users. So not everybody uses service user, that term in their work, but service user can be both clients, so patients, etc. But also it can mean the staff, the staff that you work with. So if for example, you've done a course or read an article or done some reflection that benefits your staff team, then that can then actually count as CPD as well. So there's a whole range of things that you can do that all counts as CPD. Okay, so it's very diverse. And actually, it's not always things that need to have formal CPD points. This can be kind of listening to podcast episodes and reading books and you know, things that might not have that CPD accreditation per se. Yeah, absolutely. I mean, I took up a piece of work. Mine were quite broad and varied. So I had, I did attend a conference with lots of peers and some steamy colleagues and was
在ACPC中，他们谈到了服务使用者。并不是每个人在工作中都使用服务使用者这个词，但服务使用者既可以指客户，比如患者等。也可以指员工，与你共事的员工。因此，举个例子，如果你做了一门课程、读了一篇文章或进行了一些有益于你的员工团队的反思，那么这实际上也可以算作CPD。所以你可以做各种各样的事情，这些都算作CPD。好的，所以它是非常多样化的。而且实际上，它并不总是需要正式CPD积分的事情。这可以是通过听播客节目、读书，你知道，那些本身可能没有那种CPD认证的事情。是的，完全如此。我的意思是，我承担了一项工作。我的工作范围很广，种类繁多。所以我有，我确实和一个由许多同行和一些同事参加了一个会议，并且
lucky to listen to a talk by Francesca Happey about autism girls. But then on the other end of scale, I'd done some reading around grief and I feel a bit silly now because I've got the name dropped, but I've read the Grief Collective and things like that. I absolutely had before I knew I was going to be recording this, obviously, because it was last year, but it was a new piece of work for me. So I'd gone to people that I, you know, psychologists that I knew and I'd gone through charities that deal with adolescents that have lost relatives to support me with that piece of work because it was a one-to-one young person I was working with. And I obviously did a
有幸听了弗兰西斯卡·哈皮关于自闭症女孩的演讲。但在另一个极端，我围绕悲伤做了一些阅读，我现在觉得有点傻，因为我把名字说出来了，但我读了《悲伤集体》之类的内容。我绝对是在知道我要录制这个之前就读过了，显然是的，因为那是去年，但对我的工作来说这是一项新任务。所以我去找了我认识的人，你知道，我知道的心理学家，我通过处理失去亲人的青少年的慈善机构来协助我完成那项工作，因为我当时在和一个一对一的年轻人合作。并且我显然围绕这个做了
lot of reading around that because it was the first time that I'd worked with a young person who had lost relatives, very close relative during the work that I was completing. And so I used I used that, you know, as as evidence of CPD. And also the feedback that I received from the family as evidence of CPD, CPD for my reflection afterwards when the work came to an end. And so those two parts of that reflection as evidence and that was done, that's part
大量的阅读，因为这是我第一次在一个年轻人失去亲人——在我完成工作期间失去非常亲近的亲人——的情况下与年轻人合作。所以我把这个，你知道的，作为CPD的证据。还有我从家收到的反馈作为CPD的证据，在我完成工作后为我的反思提供CPD。所以反思的这两部分作为证据被完成了，那是我提交证据时提交的一部分
of what they submitted when I put the evidence in. Okay, so it's so important you can use feedback to kind of demonstrate that you are kind of professionally developed and competent. That's really interesting to know. And I really, you know, I didn't know that you'd read The Grief Collective, but I hope that was really helpful in you getting on board
内容的一部分。好的，所以这非常重要，你可以利用反馈来证明你已经在专业上得到了发展并且胜任工作。了解这一点真的很有趣。而且我真的，你知道的，我不知道你读过《悲伤集体》，但我希望这真的对你有所帮助，让你能够理解
with kind of different people's experience of grief, actually, and how it plays out for people, for different griefs across their lives. So, yeah, I'm really heartened to hear that you've read that. Thank you. You're welcome. And I'd actually forgotten, I had forgotten that I'd put that in. And when you asked me about this, and it's funny, isn't it, that you forget the things that you, and you do forget the things that you've done. And I think that's a really, really good point. I have become a bit of a pain to the assistants and the new trainee that I've just started supervising because, you know, recording things is really important. But I was absolutely so grateful.
不同人对悲伤的实际体验，以及悲伤在人们的生活中、在不同的悲伤经历中是如何表现的。所以，是的，听到你读过这本书，我感到非常受鼓舞。谢谢。不客气。我其实已经忘了，我忘了我把这个放进去了。当向我问起这个时，这很有趣，不是吗，你会忘记你做过的事情，而且你确实会忘记你所做过的事情。我认为这是一个非常非常好的观点。我已经成了我刚开始督导的助理和新实习生的一个小麻烦，因为，你知道，记录事情真的很重要。但我真的非常感激，
It sounds really strange to LinkedIn as a system because where I had forgotten some of things that I'd done and not done records as probably as detailed as I should have done for the last couple of years because I've had a really busy time, I went back through my LinkedIn profile. And what that actually captured was more personal reflections on days, things that I'd done, and more personal, you know, photographs, for example. So I used social media where I'd shared things. And actually I could see things and how I'd felt on the day about those experiences that I've had, days that I'd been to, conferences that I'd been to. So I had my professional records, I had my diary, and I had receipts of conferences that I'd been to. And I had my CPD record
把LinkedIn作为一个系统听起来真的很奇怪，因为我忘记了自己做过的一些事情，而且在过去几年里也没有做过可能应该那么详细的记录，因为我一直非常忙，所以我重新查看了我的LinkedIn个人资料。而它实际捕捉到的是对日子的更个人化的反思、我做过的事情，以及更个人化的照片，例如。所以我使用了我分享过事情的社交媒体。实际上，我可以回顾这些事情，以及我在那天对所经历的经历的感受，我去过的地方，参加过的会议。所以我有了我的专业记录，我有我的日记，我还有我去过的会议的收据。而且我还有我的CPD记录
of this was when I did supervision and these were my supervision records. But actually I found that my LinkedIn record also said, oh, this is where I went on this day. And this was how I felt about it. This is how excited I was. So that enabled me to do the reflective pieces for those four to six actual CPD that you need to write reflective pieces on, because that's where you need the much deeper evidence of. So that's what I've been saying to the people that I supervise at the moment is it's the reflective pieces that you have to go to town on. Okay. So yeah, like you're almost having to go forensic accounting on your own life, and I'm guessing they give you the two-year window, are they, that you need to span? Yes. I chose to spread mine out, but they weren't specific about that, to be fair. They
，记录了这是我做督导的时候，这些是我的督导记录。但实际上我发现我的LinkedIn记录也写着，“哦，这是我那天去的地方。这就是我对它的感觉。我当时有多兴奋。”因此，这使我能够为那四到六个实际的CPD编写反思文章，你需要对这些写反思文章，因为那是你需要更深入证据的地方。这就是我目前对我的督导对象所说的话：你必须在反思文章上下足功夫。好的。所以，是的，就像你几乎不得不对自己的生活进行法医会计式的审查，我猜他们给你的时间范围是两年，对吗？是的。我选择将我的分散开来，但平心而论，他们对此并不具体。他们
didn't say that it has to be across the two years. There's a webinar that you can attend. They'd offered that back in March, and that counts as CPD as well, the webinar itself. If you can't go to the scheduled one, it's recorded and you can watch that back. And it was really, really good. So I'm quite a visual learner. I'm not very, I don't like to be given a great big document and just wade through that myself. There's a lot of help on the website, but I actually found it really useful to sit and watch the video. And the lady that talks you through that, it's really straightforward and she explains things really well. And she puts the slides up and she talks through what the expectations are, this is what the assessors will be looking for and I found that useful and I would recommend that anybody who finds
并没有说它必须跨越整整两年。有一个你可以参加的网络研讨会。他们在三月份提供过这个，这本身也算作CPD，网络研讨会本身就是。如果你不能去参加预定的那场，它被录下来了，你可以回看。它真的非常非常好。所以我是个相当视觉型的学习者。我不是那种，我不喜欢别人给我一大堆文档然后自己硬啃。网站上有很多帮助，但我实际上发现坐下来看视频非常有用。那个为你讲解的女士，非常直截了当，她把事情解释得很好。她把幻灯片放出来，讲解了期望是什么，评估人员会寻找什么，我觉得这很有用，我会建议任何处于
themselves in this position does that first. Don't start writing and then do it after a month, do it at the beginning and look at the examples. So there are examples on the website of your peers that have a very early career, medium, mid-term, mid-seniority, senior, and for psychologists. And they recommend looking at other types of professions as well, if you've got the time. And that was really useful I found. For layouts to see how the people have represented themselves in their CPD records. Okay, so that's good to know you're not on your own. You're not just kind of flung under the bus and like get on with it. There is, there is support around that is really useful to know. The way that I kind of keep a log of my CPD is I use my
这种境地的人首先做这件事。不要开始写，然后过了一个月才做，要在开始时做，并看看示例。所以网站上有你的同行的例子，有职业生涯初期的、中期的、中高级的、高级的，针对心理学家的。他们建议如果有时间的话，也可以看看其他类型的职业。我发现这真的很有用。通过排版来看看人们如何在他们的CPD记录中展示自己。好的，所以很高兴知道你不是孤身一人。你不是那种被直接扔进公交车底下然后“自己搞定”的人。这里有，周围有支持，了解这一点真的很有用。我记录CPD的方式是使用我的
because I'm in private practice, I use my clinical notes software which is called WriteUp and I add a patient in called Continuous Professional Development and I try to kind of add notes and kind of use the calendar function of that to add that. But definitely speaking to you is gonna make me more mindful about perhaps adding a bit more of a reflection in rather than just a date and a thing, because actually I hadn't realised that I might need to go deeper on this for specific things. I thought I was literally just ticking off what I'd done.
因为我在私立诊所工作，我使用我的临床病事记录软件，它叫WriteUp，我添加了一个名为“持续专业发展”的患者，我试着添加笔记，并利用它的日历功能来添加这些。但和你交流绝对会让我更加留心，也许要多加一点反思，而不仅仅是一个日期和一件事情，因为实际上我没有意识到我可能需要针对特定事情深入挖掘。我以为我只是在勾选我做过的事情。
Yeah, so over the last year I did a course which was about building your career. It was a year-long course actually, as it's one of my examples. And within that course, the lady that ran the course, she encourages you to look at achievements and to record those. So I've used one of her spreadsheets recently. There is also an online system and the name of it escapes me, but I'm thinking about it quite a lot. It's in the UK's private psychologist page
是的，所以在过去的一年里，我参加了一个关于建立职业生涯的课程。实际上这是一个为期一年的课程，作为我的例子之一。在那门课程中，负责课程的那位女士鼓励你审视成就并将其记录下来。所以我最近使用了她的一份电子表格。还有一个在线系统，我记不起它的名字了，但我一直在想它。它在英国私立心理学家网页上
and the path we can ensure that we could give that to your listeners, the name of the online recording system. What I did was the spreadsheet that I set up rather than it just having the recording on, because I used to just keep mine as a list. I hadn't thought about using WriteUp actually. I've only been using WriteUp for about six months. But the spreadsheet that I use now
，我们可以确保将在线记录系统的名称提供给你的听众。我做的是，我设置的电子表格不仅仅有记录，因为我过去只是把它作为一个列表。其实我没想过用WriteUp。我只用了大约六个月的WriteUp。但我现在使用的电子表格
has different tabs across the bottom. So it has one for my achievements that I sort of just almost a snapshot of achievements that things that I feel that are, um, stick with the categories that the CPD, the HCPD request, one for feedback. So if I do get an email or I do get a piece of feedback, just said to me very, very cool about that. And then one for the record. so it has the record on it so I can connect
底部有不同的标签页。所以它有一个标签页用来记录我的成就，我把它当作我感觉是成就的快照，坚持CPD、HCPD要求的类别；一个用来记录反馈。所以如果我收到一封电子邮件或者我得到了反馈，他们对我非常冷静地说过的话。然后一个是记录标签页，所以它上面有记录，我可以把它们
them together because it was the practical aspect, collating the evidence, making sure that it's in the right format etc for the HCPC. The week before I submitted I calculated that I spent 30 hours in the week before I submitted on admin formatting and tweaking the document that I sent in. So that wasn't even the hours in the month before on actually getting it. So I didn't calculate the host. That was on making sure I put things in the right order, making sure that it's right and redacting. So you have to make sure things aren't identifiable, obviously, and that they're anonymous. And for those people that are working full-time, obviously, you've got to find the extra time. But those that work in private practice, 30 hours is a lot of time. And when
连接在一起，因为这是实际的方面，整理证据，确保它符合HCPC的正确格式等。在我提交的前一周，我计算了一下，我在提交前的一周里花了30个小时用于行政、格式化和调整我提交的文件。所以这甚至还不算前一个月实际获取资料的小时数。所以我没有计算主机（花费的时间）。那是为了确保我把事情按正确的顺序排列，确保它是正确的并进行修订。所以你必须确保事情是不可识别的，显然，并且它们是匿名的。对于那些全职工作的人来说，显然，你必须找到额外的时间。但那些在私立诊所工作的人，30个小时是一段很长的时间。当
you've got families, etc., and even if you haven't got families, it's 30 hours is still a lot of time in an extra week. I had a really nice one. I can't remember the days before I submitted, just sitting there making sure it was right. And the other thing that the lady did say who did the webinar was that if the assessor can't make sense to evidence, because you have to connect things together, and they have to go in on separate documents, you can't just put them all in one. So if they can't connect things together, it's really tricky for them to understand which document links to the other. So I was wanting to be really sure that it's clear. Yeah, okay. And that was going to be my next question, really, how many hours has this taken? But you've beautifully answered that within your
你有家庭等，即使你没有家庭，30个小时在额外的一周里仍然是一段很长的时间。我有一个非常好的经历。我不记得提交前的那些天了，只是坐在那里确保一切正确。那位做网络研讨会的女士说的另一件事是，如果评估人员看不懂证据，因为你必须把事情联系起来，而且它们必须放在单独的文档中，你不能把它们全放在一个文档里。所以如果他们无法将事情联系起来，他们很难理解哪个文档链接到另一个文档。所以我希望非常确定它是清晰的。好的，好的。这本来是我的下一个问题，实际上，这花了我多少小时？但你已经在
within your kind of answer anyway, like that. And that's, you know, for me in private practice, that's 30 hours of unpaid work, you work. I guess it's factoring that in. And do you think with hindsight, you could have done your regular recordings better to speed that up? Or do you think it's always gonna be a very involved process, Carly? I think as a senior leader, historically,
你的那种回答中完美地回答了这个问题，就像那样。而且，对我来说在私立诊所里，那是30个小时的无偿工作，你工作。我想这就是把这一点考虑进去。你认为事后看来，你可以把你的常规记录做得更好来加快这个速度吗？还是你认为这永远是一个非常复杂的过程，卡莉？我认为作为一名高级领导，从历史上看，
so I did five years as a senior leader on really large teams. And I think that as you re-work your way up the ladder, you can become slightly more, I think you know that you achieve your CPD through development because you're doing personal development plans, courses, you go to conferences.
所以我曾在非常大的团队中担任过五年的高级领导。我认为当你一步步晋升时，你会变得稍微更加……我认为你知道你是通过发展来实现你的CPD的，因为你在做个人发展计划、课程、你去参加会议。
As a psychologist, you are training and ensuring other people are receiving their CPD and you're ticking it off with the line manager. But, and you know, as a psychologist, it's incredibly important. I think we're very good at knowing we have to train and develop. I mean, keep a list. We attend our supervision because it's strummed into us in training, how important that is, and especially reflective practice. I think we know it's there.
作为一名心理学家，你在培训并确保其他人接受他们的CPD，并且你正在与直线经理一起勾选它。但是，而且你知道，作为一名心理学家，这是极其重要的。我认为我们非常擅长知道我们必须培训和发展。我的意思是，保持一个清单。我们参加督导，因为在培训中这已经被灌输给我们了，这是多么重要，尤其是反思性实践。我想我们知道它在那里。
But to show that as evidence, to show it to the right level, particularly the part around standards. So the standards say that there should be a continuous record, but it should show a variety of evidence and it should the three and four kind of cover. It should benefit the service users and it should, three and four kind of cover, it should benefit the service users and it should benefit us, our quality of practice. And I think that is the bit that's more tricky because I've got to write it in such a way that it's synced, but still is at a high enough quality to show how it's reflected. And I think that's the
但要将其作为证据展示出来，展示到正确的水平，特别是围绕标准的那部分。所以标准说应该有一个持续的记录，但它应该展示各种各样的证据，并且它应该，第三和第四种涵盖了。它应该造福服务使用者，并且它应该，第三和第四种涵盖了。它应该造福服务使用者，并且它应该造福我们、我们的实践质量。我认为这是更棘手的部分，因为我必须以一种简洁的方式来写它，但仍然要达到足够高的质量来展示它是如何被反思的。我认为那是
bit where I wanted to choose the right evidence. So I had to do all of my records were adequate enough to demonstrate my skills and abilities from the last two years and then choose ones to write about. So it did change my mind probably about six times to understand which ones to write about. And that was the bit that took the time, Marianne, to be honest. So I wrote a couple and then discarded them. And I don't know if that's because I'm a psychologist and I was procrastinating about getting it right, or whether it was because I am the sort of person
我想选择正确证据的部分。所以我必须确保我所有的记录都足够充分，以证明我过去两年的技能和能力，然后选择一些来写。所以我大概改了六次主意，才弄清楚到底该写哪几个。玛丽安，老实说，正是那部分耗费了时间。所以我写了几个然后又抛弃了。我不知道这是不是因为我是一名心理学家，我在为做得对不对而拖延，还是因为我是那种
that thinks like an assessor, because obviously I've worked with, for years I've worked with for years I've worked and a lot of other people so I helped trainees to get on courses you know help them with their development. I've been a trainer myself. I read a lot of comments on Facebook which was from people saying don't overthink it because you know they've done theirs quite simplistically and still passed. So I did in the end, I was quite strict to myself and thought it can be good enough. Because the one thing I wanted to say to your listeners today was that the lady who ran the talk said that if the assessors aren't happy, they will come back to you and they will talk it through with you and say, this is what's missing and here is your second chance and so please don't worry that you are just
像评估人员一样思考的人，因为显然我工作过，多年来我一直和很多人一起工作，所以我帮助实习生进入课程，你知道，帮助他们发展。我自己就是一名培训师。我在Facebook上读到了很多评论，来自那些说“不要过度思考”的人，因为他们做得很简单，却依然通过了。所以我最后对自己相当严格，认为“这已经足够好了”。因为我想在今天对你们的听众说的一件事是，主持演讲的那位女士说，如果评估人员不满意，他们会回来找你，和你讨论并说：“这是遗失的内容，这是你的第二次机会”，所以请不要担心，如果有什么遗失，你就会突然被从注册表中除名，这真的很让人放心。而且她并不是完全可以自由发挥、随便交什么东西上去。我认为我们必须认真对待审核。但她非常清楚，如果由于某种原因我们没有完全达到标准，还有第二次，而且她暗示还有第三次机会来把事情做好，如果我们还没有完全理解这个过程的话。所以当我写到大约第三篇和第四篇时，我在想，这是对的吗？这是对的吗？所以我，你知道，我想“不要过度思考，交上去，如果这就是明显的证据，我还有一些备用的可以交上去，如果我没完全弄对的话。”
going to be suddenly struck off the register if there's something missing and that was really reassuring and it's not she wasn't completely free-range just to hand anything in I think we've got to take it seriously, the audit. But she was very clear that if for some reason we can't quite hit the mark, there is a second and she intimated a third opportunity to get it right if we haven't quite understood the process. So when I got to sort of my third and fourth pieces, I was thinking, is this the right one? Is this the right one? And so I, you know, I thought don't overthink it, put it in and if that's what an obvious evidence I've got some in the bag to hand them if I haven't got it quite right.
好的，知道这不是一种“一击出局”的情况，真的让人非常放心。你对那些审查你提交内容的人有什么了解吗？他们是同为HCPC注册的专业人士吗？他们是训练有素的行政人员吗？到底是谁在决定我们是否达标呢？我们得到的保证是，至少有一名评估员将与我们属于同一专业，我想，其实我没想到这个答案。我想这其实是在网络研讨会结束时的问答环节中提到的，如果我没记错的话，但这是明确说明的，我并不介意到底是谁，但我认为这实际上非常有趣且有用，因为那正是我所
Okay, that really is reassuring to know that it's not a first first strike and out situation. Do you have a sense of the people that are reviewing what you submit? Are they fellow HCPC registered professionals? Are they trained administrators? Who is it that's determining whether we are enough? So we were reassured that at least one of the assessors would be of the same profession as us, which I thought I actually I hadn't expected that answer. I think it was in a Q&A actually at the end of the webinar that I think somebody asked that if my memory serves me correctly, but it was definitely stated and I wasn't precious about who it was, but I thought that was actually really interesting and useful to know because that was what I was
写的。我是一个说话比较直白的人，但你知道，因为在我写的时候，我是一个说话比较直白的人，但实际上在我写的时候，我在想，我精简了内容，因为我有字数限制，这很好。我认为人们有写得太多的倾向，我不得不减少我的一些解释，我觉得我漏掉了两三件事，但我必须加以限制。我想，好吧，因为字数限制我漏掉了这个，但希望某个在专业领域内的人在阅读时能够理解
writing. I'm quite a plain speaking person, but know because as I was writing I'm quite a plain speaking person but I actually as I was writing I was thinking I reduced down because I have word limits which is good. I think the tendency to write far too much and I had to reduce down some of my explanations and I felt like I was missing a couple of things out, but I had to limit. And I thought, right, I've missed this out because of the word limit, but hopefully somebody is reading it within the professional understand
这些遗漏，为什么，我这里是什么意思。所以我对此感到放心，绝对是的。还有时间尺度，你知道的，我只是觉得，一旦它交上去了，你就只能放手了，因为电子邮件上确实写着，可能需要8到12周才能回复你，这很长一段时间。
with these emissions, why, what I mean here. So I felt reassured by that, absolutely. And also the time scale, you know, I just thought, once it's gone in, you've just got to get it out because it does say on the email, it might take eight to 12 weeks to come back to you, which is a lot of time.
确实很长，但我认为人们在大约一个月左右就收到了回复，不过我认为那些人交得很早。所以我确实在想，8到12周更接近提交截止日期。我交得有点早，但并没有提前太多。所以我有点觉得它已经交上去了，我现在把它忘掉，然后拭目以待。拭目以待，请随时向我们通报最新情况，我们可以向大家提供一点小小的更新。
It is, but I think people have been hearing back with it around about a month, but I think those people had handed it in early. So I do wonder if the eight to 12 weeks is closer to the submission date. I handed mine in a little bit early, but not massively. So I'm kind of thinking it's in, I forget about it now, and just wait and see. Wait and see and do keep us posted and we can give a little update to people.
我们还有另一个关于HCPC的上下两部分特辑，这是这些剧集的第二集。我们还与尼克进行了交谈，他是一位法律支持人员，帮助人们浏览HCPC投诉流程。所以如果任何观看或收听此节目的人觉得，“哦，那会是一个有趣的观看或收听，”请务必也关注那一集。卡莉，这次谈话太让人开眼界了，你知道的，如果你能给某人一个建议，会是什么？实际上，我没有，我没有提到，我和我的督导讨论过我的情况。
We have another, there's a little two part special on on HCPC actually and this is the second of those episodes. We've also had a chat with Nick who's a legal supporter who helped people navigate the HCPC complaints process. So if anyone watching or listening to this is like, oh that would be an interesting watch or listen, please do look out for that one as well. Carly, this has been so eye-opening and, you know, if you could offer one piece of advice to someone, what would it be? Actually, I didn't, and I didn't mention, I talked mine through with my supervisor.
我很幸运能接受海伦·丹特教授的督导。她多年来一直是我的同事和同行。我在临床培训期间遇到了海伦，我认为与一个非常了解你、也了解你工作的人交谈的好处在于，你可以对他们非常诚实和坦率，既表达你对这个过程的感受——因为没有人有时间突然放下一切去添加那些耗费大量时间的东西。那30个小时充满了添加、格式化和痛苦。但也包括投入信息、撰写信息的最初几周。但和你的督导谈论这件事真的非常非常有帮助。而且海伦
So I'm lucky to be supervised by Professor Helen Dent. She's been a colleague and a peer for many years. I met Helen during my clinical training and I think the benefits of speaking to someone who knows you well and also knows your work is you can be very honest and open with them about both your feelings about the process because nobody has the time to suddenly just drop everything and add something in that takes so much time. It was a 30 hours around all the adding and the flattening and the agonizing. But it was also the early weeks of putting the information, writing about that. But talking to you in a course supervisor about it was really, really useful. And Helen
本人也经历过这一切。所以她给出了绝对的智慧之言。海伦现在退休了，所以她经历过这一切，也做过这一切。我发现这真的真的很有帮助。还有就是对人们诚实地说我感到担心、紧张，尽管我大概知道我需要做什么，但只是，你知道的，与同行分享。当我完成时，我发了一条有趣的帖子，看到大家在下面的评论让我笑了，也让我意识到其他人也处于第二种状态，这让我感觉好多了。所以我并不孤单，这真的很重要。真的很重要，这也促成了我们今天能够一起交谈，
herself had been through it as well. So she gave absolute words of wisdom. Helen's retired now, so she's been there and done that. And I found that really, really helpful. And also just being honest with people that I was worried, nervous, even though I kind of knew what I needed to do, just being, you know, sharing with peers. I put a funny post on when I'd finished and just seeing people's comments underneath made me laugh and made me realise that other people were in the second position and that made me feel better. So I didn't feel alone, which was really important. Really important and it's also led us to talking together today as well,
因为我想这是我们以前没有在播客中谈论过的事情。对每个人来说，无论他们处于职业生涯的哪个阶段，这都将非常有用。你觉得闪电会不会击中两次？所以，你知道，我非常希望你能得到那个绿色的勾号，一切都能顺利进行。明年或者下一次注册时，你会被重新放回100%的同一个池子里吗？还是你会得到一个，你会得到几年的豁免期？显然不是。显然，每个人，是的，每个人绝对都可以再次被选中。所以我确实从这里和那里的一些人那里听说，他们在两年后又被选中了。所以，是的，我想这正是“随机”这个词的最终定义吧。
because I thought that's something we've not spoken about for the podcast. It would be so useful for everybody, whatever stage of their career they're at. Do you have a sense of where the lightning can strike twice? So, you know, I very much hope that you will get the green tick and everything will go forward okay. Are you put back into the same pool of 100% next year or next registration time or do you get kind of a, do you get a little few years out? Apparently not. Apparently, everybody, yeah, everyone can absolutely be chosen again. So I have heard from a few people here and there that were picked up in two years time again. So yes, I guess that is the whole definition of the word random at the end.
确实如此。所以不像《饥饿游戏》，如果你在《饥饿游戏》中幸存下来，你就不会再次被抽中。像这样，你可能在两年后再次被叫到，但希望这个过程会更顺利，因为你将确切地知道期望是什么。但我希望任何听过或看过这一集的人都会发现这是一个更顺利的过程，因为希望这真的能帮助他们思考他们需要记录什么。也许他们会保留一个CPD日志
Yeah, indeed. So not like the Hunger Games where if you survive the Hunger Games, you don't get reaped again. Like this, you could get called again in two years, but hopefully it will be a smoother process because you'll know exactly what the expectations are. But I hope that anyone who's listened or watched this episode will find it a smoother process, because hopefully it will really help them to think about what they need to be recording. Perhaps they keep a CPD log
，这样他们就可以轻松地找到诸如此类的事情。就像我说的，我使用WriteUp。我知道黛博拉·金斯顿博士推荐了一个电子表格，我想它算是一种电子表格，但我想你需要为此支付月费。所以我去获取那里的详细信息。但如果任何人想要了解WriteUp是如何工作的演示，以及我是如何将其用于我的CPT以及如何将其用于我的客户的，显然我不会向你展示我的客户可识别数据，请务必让我知道。卡莉，非常感谢你抽出时间。就像我说的，请随时向我们通报你的审核结果。谢谢你愿意与我们的听众分享你的知识、
so they can easily go to the kind of things. Like I said, I use WriteUp. I know that Dr. Deborah Kingston recommends a spreadsheet that you, I think it is kind of a spreadsheet, but I think you pay a monthly fee for that. So I will get the details of that. But if anyone wants to get a bit of a demo about how WriteUp works and how I use that for my CPT and how I use that for my clients, obviously I won't show you my client identifiable data, please do let me know. Carly, thank you so much for your time. Like I said, please do keep us posted with the outcome of your audit. And thanks for being so willing to share your knowledge,
技能和专业知识。如果人们想更多地了解你，他们最好去哪里找你？所以我的诊所Pointn Psychology在LinkedIn上，搜索Dr. Carly Poynton，我也有一个Facebook页面，叫做Poynton Psychology。太棒了。我一定会确保这些链接显示在屏幕上，并且也会在描述和节目备注中提供。非常感谢你抽出时间，我期待在未来某个时候与你再次交流。不客气。很高兴和你交谈。保重。
skills and expertise with our audience. If people want to know more about you, where's the best place for them to head to? So my practice point in psychology is on LinkedIn on there under Dr. Carly Pointnton and I do have a Facebook page as well which is Poynton Psychology. Amazing. I will make sure that those links are on screen and they are in the description and show notes as well. Thank you so much for your time and I will look forward to catching up with you at some point in the future. You're welcome. Lovely speaking to you. Take care.
谢谢。这真是一期超级有用的节目，与卡莉的交谈也非常愉快。有时我们确实遇到了一些声音和连接问题，但我非常希望最终上传的节目达到了效果，并且大家能够在正确的时间理解我们所说的一切。如果你觉得这一集有帮助，请务必给我点个赞，请务必给我留个言。也请在YouTube的评论区互相交流。让我们互相支持。让我们振奋人心。让我们真正把这里打造成一个美好的社区。卡莉在节目中提到了我的书《悲伤集体：生命、失落与学会治愈的故事》。如果你想买一本，可以点击我个人简介中的链接或描述中的链接。
Thank you. What a super useful episode that was and a lovely chat with Carly. We did have some sound and connection issues at times, but I'm very much hoping that ultimately the uploaded episode has done the trick and that it was possible to work out everything we were saying at the right time. If you found this episode helpful, please do drop me a like, please do drop me a comment. Please do engage with one another in the comments on YouTube as well. Let's support each other. Let's raise people up. Let's really make this a wonderful community to be part of. Carly mentioned my book, The Grief Collective, Stories of Life, Loss and Learning to Heal in the episode. And if you would like to get a hold of that, you can click the link in my bio or in the description
谢谢。这真是超级有用的一期节目，和卡莉的聊天也非常愉快。有时我们的声音和连接确实出了一些问题，但我非常希望最终上传的节目能够解决问题，并且大家能够在合适的时间听清我们所说的一切。如果你觉得这期节目有帮助，请给我点赞，给我留言。也请在YouTube的评论区互相交流。让我们互相支持。让我们振奋人心。让我们真正把这里建设成一个美好的社区。卡莉在节目中提到了我的书《悲伤合集：生命、失去与学会治愈的故事》。如果你想买一本，可以点击我个人简介或描述栏中的链接
or on the show notes. But it's a really nice way of learning about grief, especially if you don't have that personal resonance with grief yourself as well. I was talking to a Sun journalist today about grief and trauma. Grief is around us all the time and having an awareness of it can be so important so that we're better able to understand ourselves,
或者在节目笔记中。但这是了解悲伤的一种非常好的方式，特别是如果你自己对悲伤没有那种个人共鸣的话。我今天和一位《太阳报》的记者讨论了悲伤和创伤。悲伤一直围绕在我们身边，对它有所意识非常重要，这样我们才能更好地理解我们自己、
our friends, our family and our clients. So please do check that out. I also mentioned WriteUp in there. If you'd welcome a free two-week trial to check Write up out yourself. Please do check the link in the description or contact me by sending me a DM and we can sort you out at not just the free two week trial but a demo with me and I can show you how I record my CPD but also how I use it to organise my clinic and make it run so much more smoothly. The kindest thing you can do for any podcaster
我们的朋友、家人和客户。所以请务必去看看。我在里面也提到了WriteUp。如果你希望获得两周的免费试用亲自体验一下Writeup，请查看描述中的链接，或者通过发送私信联系我，我们可以为你安排不仅是两周的免费试用，还有由我进行的演示，我可以向你展示我是如何记录我的CPD的，以及我是如何用它来组织我的诊所并使其运行得更顺畅的。你能为你认可的任何播客做出的最善良的事情
that you rate is to subscribe or follow their show. So please do that for me if you do enjoy the content that I create and the guests that I bring on, the more engagement we get, the better and better guests we get too. If you are an aspiring psych, please do come and join my free Facebook group, The Aspiring Psychologist Community with Dr. Marianne Trent. If it's your time and you're ready for the next step in your career, please do consider the Aspiring Psychologist membership and for that more bespoke touch, the Ready to Rise Program,
就是订阅或关注他们的节目。所以如果你喜欢我创作的内容和我请到的嘉宾，请为我这样做，我们获得的互动越多，我们请到的嘉宾也会越来越好。如果你是一位有志于成为心理学家的人，请来加入我的免费Facebook群组：由玛丽安·特伦特博士创建的“有志心理学家社区”。如果时机已到，你准备好迎接职业生涯的下一步，请考虑“有志心理学家会员计划”；如果想要更定制化的服务，可以考虑“准备崛起计划”，
which I'm very excited about and having some lovely one-to-one sessions with people for two. My name is Diakolo La Amujo. I am a recent psychology graduate from Ireland. I am also an aspiring clinical psychologist. Dr. Marion's book, The Clinical Psychologist Collective has been so helpful to me on this journey to becoming a clinical psychologist. As I plan to continue postgraduate studies in the UK, I found it extremely useful that this book provided in-depth information on the UKD Clean Side Application process. I enjoyed reading about the experiences of both qualified and trainee clinical psychologists. The various narratives were my favorite part of the book as
对此我非常兴奋，并且正在与人们进行一些美好的一对一咨询。我的名字叫迪阿科洛·拉·阿穆约。我是爱尔兰的一名近期心理学专业毕业生。我也是一名有志于成为临床心理学家的人。玛丽安博士的书《临床心理学家合集》在我成为临床心理学家的这段旅程中对我非常有帮助。由于我计划在英国继续攻读研究生，我发现这本书提供了关于英国D-ClinPsy申请过程的深入信息，这极其有用。我喜欢阅读已获得资格和正在实习的临床心理学家的经历。各种故事是我最喜欢的部分，因为
everyone's story was different and it provided amazing insights into the clinical psychology journey. I would definitely recommend this book to anyone interested in psychology and aspires to become a clinical psychologist. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
每个人的故事都不同，它为临床心理学之旅提供了惊人的见解。我绝对会把这本书推荐给任何对心理学感兴趣并立志成为临床心理学家的人。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。